bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour surtout
nos jeunes amis puisque nous sommes
mercredi ils retrouveront eric noëlla et
leurs héros préférés bien sûr cet après
midi dès 14 heures 30
en ce qui nous concerne nous à partir de
12h30 et nous nous retrouverons patrice
laffont et son jeu les mariés de la deux
et puis à 13h le journal vous sera
présentée par philippe lefait notre
soirée quant à elle commence à 20h45
avec un film de la collection contre
jour une collection dirigée par jacques
deray ce sera le premier film réalisé
pour la télévision par michel vianey la
porte d'or avec gérard klein et laure
killing mais regardez plutôt ces
quelques images